OCS la bugia suboxone cinema city prison
ils disent tous la même chose Je le
croirai quand je le verrai
mais c'est la croyance à l'envers qui vient en premier
alors seulement pouvez-vous le voir Je vous demande
d'utiliser votre imagination nous avons un
coup à  ça et j'ai besoin de la meilleure équipe mon
objectif en ce moment est que ma fille
me dise de dire non je vais dire non
ce que nous faisons est dangereux je suis prêt à
prendre ce risque je ne sais pas si je suis
comment ça fait  vous sentez que vous mettez votre
vie en danger et qu'en est-il de votre
famille
toutes nos familles savent pourquoi nous nous sommes
inscrits pensez-vous déjà à maman vous
ne pouvez pas la laisser nous abattre aussi avons-nous
fait une erreur j'ai quatre personnes
dont  les vies dépendent de mon jugement je
ne peux pas vous laisser douter de moi qu'est-ce
qu'il est cela pourrait être la personne qui
découvre la vie sur Mars j'ai besoin de vous ici
vous y allez
Oh si j'ai l'opportunité de faire un travail
aussi important imaginez la
responsabilité du  l'astronaute épaule
les sacrifices personnels qu'ils ont
endurés
j'ai besoin de gens qui sont  va faire la chose la plus difficile
et ensuite ils s'attachent à
une fusée et ils risquent
déjà suffisamment leur vie,
c'est déjà cinq personnes
[Music]
accomplissant le destin de 8 milliards la
première saison, nous en avons besoin DeLuna facteur
expulsion douleur
COC soutient tous les cinémas hé hé OCS
visite  fan USC
vous